so our next speaker is Miguel from
trustee and he will tell you about
processing large amount of hotel reviews
with Python and I guess it'll just start
when he's ready ok looks ok yep so
thanks for being here my talk I should
have changed the title a little bit i
think is you wouldn't expect like a
hardcore NLP talk and there's gonna be a
lot of code in this talk most like a you
know the sign and architectural hbu how
we do things trust you so starting with
the normal slide of about me um I'm
Colombian like the last speaker so I
don't I think there's a organizational
reason behind to Colombia speakers one
after the other a man no valina I just
came here two months ago before I wasn't
in Munich and I Wilfred trust you which
is an company Munich as a data something
I wear many hats so sometimes I do basic
data pipeline processing and all the
time i work with machine learning a
little bit I we work in vitam around two
years only so I'm kind of embarrassed
for that but so so far so good I really
love the working with Python and before
coming in Munich I found it a munich
data geeks I it's I like to call it like
the largest machine learning meet up in
Germany probably the guy from Berlin
gonna disagree on that but it's actually
true I can prove it like like we had one
of the thoughts that was presented
yesterday we had we had it some months
ago in Munich before just saying that
anyways ok so the agenda are three
things first I'm going to talk the
problem description basically what we do
then the tools we used to do that that
include fighting and other technologies
so that's like the hell and finally
I going to show you a sample application
where we serve use what I just described
and just a technology technology
demonstration um so trust you we we have
three products the company has two
products one is a social media
monitoring other is service in we have a
data something we call the meta review
which is what I'm going to talk about it
we work for hotels so we all the all the
things we do we do it for hotels in in
for the metal review widget or the
product i'm going to show you we talked
to the product this problem so we work
from with reviews from users and you
know you probably use something like
Yelp or four square and you go to a
place you write a review or something
that same thing happens with hotels some
people go to hotel they don't like
something they write it about it but
they use different website and they use
different languages so the goal of the
company is to create a summary of all
hotels on the planet based on the on the
or what people talk about so we create
this widget we call it a piece of HTML
when we try to summarize and the hotel
so if you sit within the in the upper
left corner there's a score that we
calculate based on all the average score
of all the website we crawl and then we
have like summary sentence we try to get
the most important information from from
from the hotel so in this case the hotel
and review you I don't know if you can
read that but it's in the Las Vegas
Strip it's a it's a hotel in Las Vegas
design hotel we also do some ranking so
we rank hotels based on what people say
and different categories like this i
noted probably i cannot dismiss HTML
sorry and we have some good to know and
we show highlight from reviews we also
get these pieces of text probably you
can read here let's call it we call it
snippets its thing we attract from
review so particular pieces of tech that
we find interesting in this case perfect
for design enthusiasts or dread
restaurant huge bathroom etc etc
um so we also provide this as data as an
API in so in mostly to OTA or online
travel agencies for example this is 144
hit month another one that use our data
its kayak and so the other like famous
web search engines that I cannot say so
you can imagine that the doing this or
getting all these are sorry we also
support at many languages so it's not
only for English we support a Thai
Chinese and so on and so forth so we
take all review from all languages and
we put it here in a summary um so you
might imagine to to sort of accomplish
this we need to do throughout particular
task like crawling a we do some natural
language processing of semantic analysis
or we attract I mean Lee people some
people talk about the Barrow mother from
the restaurant so on so we have to the
duplicate hotels reviews with
duplication where you have already
something in your database and you don't
want to write it over after you crow
then we have ranking recommendation and
other machine learning a problem that
you might be familiar with um the stack
simple the stack I'm going to talk a bit
more about the technology but we have
two main layers this one is the bad
layer and the batch layer sorry uh in in
that we receive data from the crawling
we process it and to do that we use
Hadoop and after that we write that data
into normal databases that are dinner
with by the application layer that is
also Python applications like in flats
or the jungle and etc and I'm going to
talk you about the the bat layer model
in this town um so some numbers to to
talk of it we support 25 different
languages we have in our database more
than half a million more properties we
crawl daily around 30 millions reviews
we have to duplicate those reviews
against another 250
millions of review that we have already
in our database drove gld nama around
200,000 daily new reviews to process um
and you know what that mean right that
mean a lot of texts we have to work with
a lot of text in aa in working with such
a large amount of that basically mean
you can boil down everything to for
things like you have to clean filter
join an aggregate and that's like even
machine learning you can boil down to to
to sort of like this actions and when I
start telling you how we work you start
like creating a sort of like a graph so
first you have to crawl the web site
then you have to clean it or extract the
text from it and then you have to do
maybe for the cleaning applying some
machine learning so many LP and data
from these different steps are put into
another one that does something else and
in the steps might be in different
technologies and we have it actually in
that way out of requirement out of that
you grew up your environment igloo sort
of naturally so it's not limited to
Python for example the step can be
running hopefully running parallel so
you can crawl different web pages at the
same time you shouldn't have like a
linear thing because then it will not
take forever and then in step have
complete dependency amongst them so you
you one step will depend on several and
other step will depend on those so sort
of create so you have several
requirement first one is that technology
want how are you going to process what
in which language you're going to write
those those task then you have to look
for a way to parallel y'all ready say we
use a do but you know pretend I didn't
say that so you have to look for a way
to to to parallel this and then you have
to look for a way to sort of manage
those dependencies or in other words do
some sort of orchestration so talking
about the technology I'm not going to go
into Python I know we all love fightin
that's why we are here so I'm not gonna
go and say Python is the best and we but
we use some a lot of Python in our code
wait i was around eighty percent and and
why because it has new pie it has a NLT
k in many many libraries that are useful
to actually do what we do and what is
what is what is nice about it is in it
something that was previously mentioned
in here is that we don't have this to
language problem so we can do our
prototyping in in python and then we
move straight to production or well
obviously after a prototype you have to
clean up some stuff but then it's you
use the same language to for both in for
doing next this we use ipython or
Jupiter and in other technologies
together and then we move that to a to
our production code and that's very nice
at the end that's I think it's now one
of the big wins that you get when you
use Python so scaling tibial you I mean
Hadoop is everywhere right now cook
who's familiar with Hadoop please say
familiarity who is not familiar with
Hadoop ok so I'm going to give a fast
introduction I mean I was I it's kind of
hard to explain hadoukens in sentences
but imagine this it's a distributed file
system where you can run to particular
set of tasks map and reduce in you can
write anything on top of that so imagine
a lot of machines with deep with the
five sitting that has is distributed to
two main functions and that's more or
less how it works I know it's not enough
to split a dupe but so in order to
continue to the talk let's let's say we
are we are familiar with it ah but
Hadoop is equals to Java right so
imagine say we love Python so how do we
do that for by the way this is the
picture I took during the last Java meet
up I went to
no kidding here oops so Python + Hadoop
there there there are many ways to use
Python and Hadoop actually the normal
the standard one will be used to do
streaming that basically allows you to
run anything on top of Hadoop so how to
take share charge of sending five giving
the file to the to the code you one that
has some overhead but there other way
waste like mr. Joe poro see that is a
Java framework hey Luigi I'm going to
talk about with you in a second so for
Hadoop streaming and that's going to be
a little bit of explanation for those
are not familiar with with my reduce if
you're familiar with the unit bash that
should be quick that's basically what
Hadoop does so you have an input that
you cut into another process that we
call it map after the map that does
something he generate some key in some
data that t is then sort in this guy can
be by the sort command in your in your
computer in this path based on that key
all the date of that belongs to that key
to the I reduce a process and then you
generate the output that basically
Hadoop in a nutshell in your local
machine in the real life you will run
this something in the Hadoop cluster you
will run it like this and basically you
have to also provide two different one
map and what reduce for Hadoop streaming
can be any technology in this example I
have a Python um yeah but if you want to
change several step as you just
described it before then you have to
rise something else to like when you run
one process then you pass the output to
the next one and in and that boys on
some time to just write in bash scripts
and who likes to write bash scripts
raise hands here really really ok there
people people who know me so that takes
me to D to D to the next thing how do i
customize my how do I orchestrate this
how do we manage all these different map
and reduce steps and put it together in
a nice way so relate it together and
then it comes and we start using this
one
Luigi M is a from the description so
it's a Peyton for Python framework for
data flow definition and execution in
plain English it means that using Python
you can describe at the data pipeline
and flow in any technology basically and
we abuse it for a year and we're pretty
happy with it it gives you the pendency
definition it comes straight with a
double integration you don't have to you
don't need to use Hadoop to use Luigi
but it comes straight away you can use
it you can use Hadoop HDFS it gives you
an object-oriented abstraction to work
with it allows for elysium resume
failure jobs like many thing I basically
said it yours Luigi now and then a nice
command-line integration and you can
also visualize the visualization
actually not that good but it works so
an example some code finally this is a a
a a Hadoop sorry I Luigi task is not
Hadoop it's just a task that you can put
together with it with different ones in
it it can run locally in your machine on
your machine with no problem and this is
what it takes to write a luigi task in
you have a parameter that is
automatically it becomes a command line
parameters you can use this straight
from the common online and you can pass
it if you run this each function has a
requirement that can be a another task
so that's the way you put together the
dependencies this case is a imagine is
another tat that give a a text I'm going
to show how to run this then the output
each that produces an output in that
output is then pass to the next task and
each function has Iran where you write
your business logic if you want to run
this in Hadoop MapReduce is just
basically the same it the same sample
the same logic the only thing is that
you have to provide a a mapper and a
reduce and you can have like this data
flow visualization I'm going to get
gonna
go of the presenter mode and going to
show you how to run this easily a let's
make it big here okay okay it's not
working okay here i have no idea what it
doesn't work ok now it's it's yeah it's
appear to be working ok so let's go here
I'm I'm trusting in the Wi-Fi it now so
please oh thanks oh well yeah it's kind
of like sad let's put it in the middle
here oh the sort of tossing work
expected with the arm with the this
maybe I can can switch the appearance to
or you when you put this deed topics all
right I just want to change the color
but I ok maybe there's no another one
foreground backgrounds put it to white
something like that oh crap anyways yes
we're with me so uh huh let's go work
out right 042 banku oh can I don't know
where it is where's the code I'm
supposed to show now that's a bit
embarrassing I'm supposed to have this
here but ok oh yeah it's called the demo
okay let's see let's okay it's not there
oh yeah I found it oh quit okay now I
know it's here ah so this is a a limo
it's basically the same code that you
showed so input test is a lui external
task basically gives me a HDFS target is
a file on HDFS and this is the same code
that you showed basically that's the
only difference and the small amount if
I want to run this it's just demo and
what is telling me is all the parameter
it comes automatically in what does I
can run in this case so if i give
workout it will sorry you will fail of
course because i haven't passed any
parameter to that to that thing so i
will face parameter today is 2015 05
what day is today 30 yeah okay any start
running and now there's a MapReduce job
running right now with this only piece
of code in talking about visualization
you can this is production data this is
actually something that is running right
now this is life thing I'm going to look
for a tassel how you can check all the
different tasks tasks are running so you
know it update a database generally this
task are more cool to show and this is a
example of a workflow I just definition
so each of this task ar-ar-ar Python or
other technologies in update us depend
on sayma and talking eyes on the tech
language and you can continue you can
create completely complex completely
complex quick so really nice dependence
is there and you can go down and down
and it's Turtles all the way down you
know so
you can go like this dessert the green
thing that it means that it's done so
it's a way to sort you can place
different different steps now
interesting you can run this local in
your machine and you can even sort of
model the data sign workflow when you
have to you know do cross validation or
feature extraction and so on let's go
back to the slides so so Luigi in
summary give us a minimal boilerplate
code to define tasks you can
programmatically find dependencies you
get thi synchronization and you can wrap
anything so not only Python you can put
on top of anything I'm gonna before we
used to write bash Griffin in in in
using Chrome to run everything that
therefore that's why i hate bash scripts
and do like manual cleanup in manual
failure failure recovery and it's harder
to devote this way now we use complete
nested Luigi jobs graph that what I mean
is like sometimes the task is actually
launches another Python process that
runs another Luigi so inception you know
the the movie basically the same thing
you go inside that hat is another graph
there in in all the way down this yeah
to the x go to slow down to it has
automatically automatically tried and I
still have it hard to debug sometimes
but it's way better thanks to the
visualization and sort of like the
object oriented abstraction we use it
for running basically anything
standalone executable we use it also for
database Tom's general Hadoop streaming
we also wrap some other frameworks some
of the bash script we don't want to
rewrite we put it on a luigi as well and
we just pick scripts and that's it but
the feature is that you can wrap
anything my favorite feature is that you
can wrap anything with with Rajee and
and that takes me to my next next
section I'm going to talk about peak who
i'm not talking about food no bacon
attack of a pig who similar we pick not
food the parameter which or data for
execution well you say I'm going to talk
about an analytic mo Yeon a Java
technology in a fight on meetup and a
Python conference hope you're going to
see why um I believe in the right tool
for the right job in Python we love it
it's awesome but sometimes it's not the
right tool sometimes you have to do some
data transformation that can be
expressed in a dino more elegant manner
using different different technology
that's where pic comes to pick is a high
level platform two-four creating
MapReduce programs um and I'm going to
show you why Pike pig is kind of like a
SQL desk way of defining MapReduce jobs
I'm just for comparison this is three
the same code in SQL in pig latin which
is the language that is provided to you
to create that any minute item you see
map and reduce abstraction so you have
SQL and normal as well I assume most of
you are familiar with SQL the normal
group I with a couple of aggregation
function like some some an average the
cladding is two or three depending how
you see it it's similar to SQL but not
the same is it not as relational as SQL
it's more like a relational algebra
engine and it's translated to MapReduce
jobs engine JVM basically that's how
words it converted and this is Python
and you see Python requires you to write
two different functions and then wrap it
in whatever frame were you want I mr.
Jabba Luigi and when this become more
complex than you were you have to write
more more MORE Python in pythons and
stop being spaghetti code and you don't
want that we actually had to rewrite
some code to me like me migrated from
from a Python to pick because it was
more it was cleaner to use it in that
way why what type of co well
data loading and transformation anything
that resembles sometimes like Selleck or
a complex merch of two different data
set might be easier in in in Pig you can
use other technologies but the idea is
that try to use the right tool for the
right job order logic we have it in
Python you can use pig as a luigi toss
easily because you in the wrong function
you basically launch another another
process java process running pig in the
city and you can define that is not sort
of like recommended user defined
functions as similar to the SQL one you
can define it in Python as well using
guyton so if you want to keep more like
a king in Python you can go in that
direction ah and now haha how is time
how much do it it's okay Oh perfect okay
sample application now I want to show a
sort of like a two different one
different one technology our
demonstration it's not a product is
something we developed we wanted to do
something nice and and I talked about
that i was going to sort of share how we
process reviews in in in in in this type
but i haven't mentioned reviews only in
the beginning right so now we're going
back to the actual topic ah in probably
you my thing well you know reviews well
there's a lot of texts they're boring
they're just there I and I say well if
you look closer knowing this is the
demonstration who's familiar with this
product no you so this is an awesome
shirt like the best shirt in the world
if you see it's like almost five th five
star with 1,500 reviewers so it's taught
to be something awesome right I don't
know why how is she like we got wolf
wolf and you just check the reviews
there's like I say you like it when you
I wear this is like I am ninja with a
ak-47 right so
so when you see look at closer reviews
are much more than than just like facts
about the product or the hotel or
whatever and there's a 44 44 hotels is
also have been something funny which
Atelopus it a well know the opposite but
sometimes are things like haunted houses
the source is there that much more are
there in poo in the kettle and stuff
like crazy stuff it's really crazy stuff
and I actually well so review sort of
highlights not only facts about the
product but sometimes other type of
information including the personality or
the preference of the reviewers and
that's information that i don't think
it's being used a lot i'm gonna give you
the trans you top snippet we strike part
of text from their reviews and we sort
of when we find something funny or
quirky or weird we sort of have a
database with that and um somewhere and
this is what we got this actual
reviewers writing this sent this small
days I don't know the context on today I
don't remember it sometimes it's hard
Irish dance where the Irish guy ever was
her I Raquel I just hips don't lie I
just want to know what the guy was
talking about the conscious of this it's
actually I think it's a shaquila song by
the way the last one I actually found
out why it it's like hugging a bony
supermoto and it's like the guy goes to
a hotel and say like ok they hotel is
beautiful but it not comfy and so he
said you know it's like her in a bony
supermodel she's gorgeous but you're not
gonna get a lot of you know anyways um
um so it takes me to the next thing
we're too big so when I starting the
company actually one year ago I was
working my master TC we work too vague
and stuff and say like why don't we I
mean people use word quit semilla
forward to vet here although I'm gonna
explain a little bit about it
or those there are no familiar but I
said okay people are using work to back
to train or in like you know Google News
and or I don't know Wikipedia let's go
and see what happens when we add reviews
maybe we can get something nice or or
maybe not and and that's what I'm going
to show you here and so we're too baked
introduction is a group of algorithms
it's not one technique it's a group of
models so to say it's a Nissan of
shallow learning some people sort of
like talk about work to Beckett deep
learning is not the learning you can
actually if you re actually the
outskirts of the outer set set is not
and you can when you actually check the
code or the or the architecture is just
a neural net with a hidden Idol layer
and that's it um you can see it as a
feature learning model so you get
featured you get real valued war
representations vector representation of
words so basically if you have any word
you get a vector that's sort of like
maintain some sort of concert around it
if in tooth back in 2013 this was like a
super huge in NLP community in the
machine learning because if you apply
this function of this transformation or
summation to the back to representing
those words you get the result of Queen
so basically this is asking and a keen
is to a man as a woman is to a queen in
the model could answer that queen that
give that answer without knowing
anything about what is female or male or
what is a queen Erick or a king and in
this I took it from this you totally
have to check this website web a blog
post it's really interesting explains a
lot and there's nice links there it
works like that once you learn the word
vector you can apply this sort of
transformation and you you get the sort
of like the closest vector to the result
of the transformation sometimes ends up
being the the dissolution or the answer
you're looking for um
and that's basically I'm not going to go
into details or the model because I
don't have time and I just want to show
you the results basically what is
important is the similar word gives you
nerve I've actors in inward two bags
sort of give you that and in and that
becomes really useful you can extend
that model two paragraphs and larger
documents and that's why we we wanted to
use it for to represent hotels using not
on all the words sorry all the reviews
that are created for it so we start to
generate in representation of hotel that
get some similarity so you have similar
hotels sort of clustered together based
on the on the reviews you you get in
luckily there was a Python
implementation for it a called Jensen
and we use Python and say okay so cool
its food iterating together and let's
see what happens right and and this is
basically the the what we did in the we
strike the sentences for from actually
that's pick em in Titan not only pic by
well strike sentences it's basically the
same idea you will have different steps
and I put it together we have one step
that strike the sentences another one
that learn the vibram so we can have not
representational things like New York or
Los Angeles or any other that like words
or comes that are made out of towards in
some additional tasks that we use
because sort of we need it basically
what we call closer I these are the
ideas of the hotels we use and we only
want those and this actually the what is
working in this Luigi the Luigi flow at
your show just just looks exactly the
same this is the code it's not crazy
from one task the allure model task the
same idea you have a output you have a
requirement which is the learned
background task just I just showed you
at the beginning of the talk and
you have the run which basically runs
dr. wick which generates a document
representations are not going to show
you um could I use the notebook finally
this is an old version and actually by
the way vocab breaks this completely
when i use it i don't know why but just
so this is the the same model I train I
import work to back i lo the model i I
want to use this is how the sentence are
our layout so we have the idea of the
hotel that we want to get the Centers
for the solid a model for and then we
have different a traction like
sentencing from coming from review so 1
review have different sentence so you
have to separate them right and we do
that before sorry oh sure so you have to
separate those sentences that's
basically like NLP task that we run
there's nothing we use an l TK for this
i believe and let's see if we can get
the same result from the from instead of
using google news or or a wikipedia we
can get the same result and so what i'm
asking here is the same question that
you show is i'm asking the machine to
answer the question well what is if men
what is a a sculptor phrase that so so
keenest wom n as one man is 20 it's the
opposite well you get it and um actually
I don't get I get super king I don't
know why so in this world the review
world is super king which is cool right
so it's not a queen it's a super game
feminist power now but the second one is
Queen right so it's closed now you have
to take work Queen and Queen in Keene
and queening in in review world in this
hotel word is just 134 talking about
queen size bed and you know kien sabe so
you can see there's a generals and you
know other other words that might not be
like the
things that you're going to think you're
gonna say okay that might give you a
result I look I also something I didn't
mention i train also vectors for the
city so I took all the reviews from one
city from all the hotels from one city
and solar generated another vector to
see maybe I can get something nice and I
and I'll just ask give me the vector
that is more similar to Munich and it
gives me cities like alone often by taxi
loughton and so on so sort of it keeps
series together right it's normal why
because the words are all are sort of
like the words are I mean when you talk
about German cities you usually talk
about the same or words so like the dome
or the marienplatz there are many city
with marine plot or marrying off on what
not right so German words or names and
you have the how in Heidelberg tour moon
so I say like bailing it's Vienna in
volgograd what is Volgograd is anyone
from Volgograd here ray the handle
Russia up but it's cool or it looks like
a Berlin or something and you can also
have like like a sort of like sites
right so people went write review right
about psycho I went to the Marine place
was awesome i really liked it you know
something nothing to do with the hotel
is just described the trip and you can
see like the Roman Forum give you like
me Sonia museums a patent on the
Archaeological Museum so like other side
so like the words are like closer
together in different sort of like
concepts and that's really nice in
actually at this I just add Munich and
rocks see what happened london n whereas
i believe was here buddy disappear in
Kiel I don't know why just ask the model
I put something sometimes you put
something that doesn't happen like give
you your gibberish or trash I for
example nothing to do with this and you
can have other music likes the most the
closest thing to music is rap music so a
lot of people like reg music and I
actually
it took different cities and try to put
it together in a 2d graph using an TS
any which is a so the dimensionality
reduction that kind of thing is similar
to pca and i use bouquet for doing that
a break the notebook or the old version
on book and I got this where is it it
doesn't work that I hear you so this is
the clutter of cds based on the reviews
only right so we have this one which is
basically join together Madrid Amsterdam
and the end in Miami in a one-on-one
cluster I don't know why this is the
algorithm doing this so then you have
other like your venison see are all sort
of together and then you have a linen
prac which sort of makes sense their
capitals off of stay there are similar
em I spent hours doing this you know
like putting words and see what happens
and laughing about it so we can just
stay here forever and so I don't want to
do that we have to have to the next
bigger comes early so I have to finish
um so quickly so quickly so that gives
you a similarity we have similarities
for Wars for cities and also for a hotel
so when you have similarity or hotels or
a product you can use it for
non-personalized recommender so the idea
is that if I like a particular hotel
here based the experience if I go to
another city I would like to stay in a
similar hotel that might not be true the
type but in my work and so we decided to
build a small thing in so we use the
same models I just similar models and so
I want to go to Berlin and I happen to
like the I'm a really rich person and I
you stay all the time in the Mandarin if
it doesn't work I blame the oh yeah
things so I like to stay in the Mandarin
Oriental in parts in and I just get
recommendations so this system sort of
guessed the vector and it's not only one
feature i use i use different features
like semantic features also but the main
idea is the this vector we learn and try
to recommend similar hotels in berlin so
this is a demand are in oriental it's a
really clubhotel really super duper
hotel in las vegas in paris and and sort
of like romantic luxury hotel and it
recommends me um similar things and and
sometimes the recommendation are not
that good but ah they sort of work ok
and if this is not a product is just a
technology demonstration and then
without saying anything i can only i
think saying i want to show you another
thing and i will be wish to offer st.
Christopher berlin international no but
I'm looking for something in the link
but in Paris because I'm looking for
hotels in party that i like but let's
see if it is worth sometimes it doesn't
so I'm looked for a hotel I like a
hostel in bilingual a cheap don't think
then no gave me something really bad
sometimes I cannot find it but what I
want to show it like if i add there a
hotel that i have a model for it will
give me really similar interchain to
really a cheap one a hotel or something
like that a backpacker hostel it will
give me also backpackers in billing and
I we didn't say anything about the hotel
type or anything just their works on the
reviews and some semantic categories and
that's it so I'm gonna conclude now um
where is it yep
so if we take aways and so one is it
possible to use Python as a primary
language for doing large data processing
like big data you some people call it
and the perfect the setup is not that I
mean it's good but it's not perfect
there's some issues but it works well
most of the time and however you have to
keep your ecosystem sort of open open
minded to and you have to be open-minded
so you can include more technologies and
look like waste nice ways to do that in
and the last one in from the the last
part of the talk it's like review saying
it might contain more information that
you that you think in is good if you are
if you're working for with reviews of
anything just check it out maybe you can
get extra information or even something
to amuse yourself so and that's it
questions and things questions sorry
what huh so why leak you know like it's
a data is a black box so you never know
why I mean you can take a look at the
data but you really don't know the
question was if if if I can know why it
generate them all the model instant that
way in the answer is just a black box
model so no we just like you start
running it and you pray for something
good and you try different parameters
initially this works what we did is like
a for this recommendation engine we saw
generated training sets or so like gold
fruit and then we sort of compare it
with different ways of training model so
it's more like a really brute force
approach so we have a gold standard and
then we trained several northern in test
everyone I mean there's another question
here in the bed yes I wonder a bit since
you
using Luigi but haven't mentioned
snakebite only use a snakebite so which
is also from Spotify and which is a pure
HDFS Klein yeah a pue implementation in
in Python and particularly if you're
using each year or working from command
lines it's by far a faster than the java
the java client we don't use it directly
but I know luigi has the several clients
underneath and i think one of those is a
snakebite but for some reason the 54
client is a dupe java client and due to
the JVM bootstrapping it has some delay
and it's quite annoying and yeah it's
really a good tool even if you're
completely into java on working on the
command line snake by just really
creative yeah we don't use it directly
we don't have any script using it
directly we do work with HDFS sometimes
we mostly use either when we use bash
creeps just a normal a binary that come
with the distribution or any client that
the Lydia configuration gave us because
you can get quiet and then with the
client you do whatever you want ok more
questions anyone father wonder so I
thought this was a very interesting
presentation I I was thinking have you
played with applying it to other source
of information so right now you looked
at hotel reviews have you thought about
or have you played with this in moving
in somewhere else I don't know to what
users say in forums about a particular
topic or even books have you thought
about that yeah I mean we used it for
reviews because that's the information
we work for right but it will be
interesting something I know there are
some researchers doing work to beg for
music a party church and stuffing in
musical writing and stuff and they're
getting nice results and there are
people using similar models not only
word to back but other like embeddings
generation models to work in different
and then like get information that
previously wasn't that you know that
popular and thanks on the implementation
so such a jensen you can now use it
easily so i just say if you want to try
it out this
super easy use of the gold go ahead try
it okay then thank you for the nice talk
okay thank you
you